is with us to start off this hour in
Fresno California hi welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show thank you Dave I'm so
grateful to be on your show well thank
you how can I help so I have two hundred
ninety-one thousand dollars in debt and
I am a family nurse practitioner I
worked in the outpatient setting
I made one hundred thirty five thousand
dollars a year with a guaranteed bonus
of twelve thousand dollars each year
which is coming due in about two weeks
I am also currently finishing my
doctorate in nursing practice and I have
in those who practice a doctorates
degree no why are you finishing your
doctorate what are you gonna do with it
so I would like to teach at the graduate
level for my doctorate degrees you know
that would allow an auditor yes and also
California is one of those states who
are really pushing for nurse
practitioners to have this level of
education to continue practicing okay
okay
all right how much do you like finishing
your PhD so I have four semesters left
which comes out to $28,000 mm-hmm okay
so my question is because it hasn't been
pushed into the law yet that I need this
degree should I continue to degree or
should I postpone it and what do I do
with my $12,000 bonus you continue with
the degree because it's what you want to
do with your life and it actually does
have an application there's nothing to
do because you want to teach and to
teach you're gonna need a PhD not
because we're worried about what
California is going to do with nurse
practitioners that's not the it's not
the motivation in this situation because
that's not your goal anyway right so you
continue with a degree and obviously the
291 is on hold while you're in this
program I assume so I'm paying part of
it down
why are you required to what 25,000 of
it is consumer dead oh I thought it
alone dad okay
no 25,000 is consumer that 78,000 of
student loans
I have 8,000 left on my car and I have a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars on
my house oh I thought you told me I had
two hundred ninety one thousand student
loan debt okay oh no okay so you're
working baby step two of which 78,000 a
student loan debt okay now so what I
would do there is I would budget to pay
cash for the PhD and with what's left
over I'm gonna work the debt snowball as
fast as I can
obviously $28,000 that slows you down
but you're making 150 a year mm-hmm
was everything and you got four twelve
thousand dollar bonus so when do you
need to pay tuition next week of January
okay that's where the twelve thousand is
going right okay when you need twenty
eight to finish the PhD did I hear you
right yes this is twelve of it so you
know now you need to save up the next
sixteen while in time for it to be able
to pay it in time to continue your track
right with and also living on a very
very tight budget paying down your other
debts but we're not going to borrow
money to finish the PhD we're going to
cashflow the PhD okay and I would just
stay in there and get it done I mean
you're only would you say four semesters
away I'm forced to masters away I'm
thirty years old I have a baby on the
way in three months okay but I can do it
okay so are you married I am and what is
her husband make so my husband I
actually ended up having cancer we meant
their cancer treatments he's in
remission he has not gone back to work
about a month ago we had a water leak in
the house and now that there are fires
in California the insurance companies
kind of
going around around with things with us
and so thank God we have a strong
relationship with our church and we have
church members who this is their
specialty building with a lot of leaks
and things like that so they've been
helping us when's your husband going
back to work so my husband does not have
advanced education like I do we figured
even if he went back to work the income
that he would be making would just
covered they care oh so he's gonna stay
home with the baby yeah okay okay do the
math on how we're gonna pull all this
off and I I thought I suddenly
discovered another salary that I didn't
have in the early part of our discussion
that's what I was trying to get to the
bottom of so there we go thank you yeah
perfect perfect perfect perfect so yeah
well done you got it you got a run here
but pay cash for your first step to
getting out of debt is borrowing no more
that's step one to getting out of debt
and step two is you begin to work your
debt snowball you get on beans and rice
rice and beans and you guys got to get
through this flood you've got there and
all these other things you're facing but
yeah yeah you're doing it you know you
got stuff you got this thing on the run
you do need to stay with the PhD and
finish it up because you have a use for
it
if you were simply going to be a nurse I
would not go to the expense because
there's no value but if you're going to
teach it's required
obviously in most settings and for you
to be a successful long-term professor
yeah you're gonna need that that's gonna
be and that's gonna be the the track
you're on so it sounds like you're going
that way and you're gonna be in the
classroom that's going to be wonderful
good stuff